no news is bad bad news yeah it's bad
news but
you know it's all right because I'm so
you get so used to these bad when you
first got canceled broke your heart
right oh yeah yeah that's uh the the
sitcom really because I put my hands on
that one that one really hurts yeah I
just did a game show I think that's my
future
you think that's your future I think
that's my future I'm like I'm like there
you go for [__] ever and once you get
five for one just go to another one yeah
what show is it it's called the one
percent club and it's like it's it's all
across they're going to have an American
version as well and it's a show where
you start with a hundred contestants and
they're the whole audience and you stand
in the middle and they're all sort of
seated around you and then you ask a
question that 90 of the population could
get and so you lose 10 people who get it
wrong ah 80 and then then it gets down
to the question that one percent of the
population could get wow and but they're
all IQ questions well like give me an
example of a 90 question oh a nine oh a
90 question is what photo is incorrect
you know and it'll be like a picture of
the Eiffel Tower next to the cine opera
house and the other one yeah and then
whatever can't how do you not know that
anyway but then like like a 80 question
would be uh logically which month would
sell the least amount of toilet paper
February or August
think about it all right so so uh what
would sell the lease amount August or
February I would see say the least
amount is August why because you're a
[__]
February's got the least amount of days
it's don't ever complicate these things
you're like yeah because I normally
drink a lot in August that makes me
faster that's what I was thinking so I'd
be [__] myself after the holidays yeah
it was like February February I'm
working out so my diet's pretty good
these will be firm shits not much wiping
is that what you're gonna do on the show
[__] shame people when they get it
wrong that's what I have to do oh
so what happens is at the beginning
you're just like oh you got that wrong
like that and then it's like gets
further and further you start
complimenting the people who get it
right oh right right and it starts off
with like a whole lot of really good
looking people
then they drop off quick I drop off
quick for the IQ questions they just
haven't had to develop it it's not their
fault right and then and then it's
always some like bookish nerd at the end
who's just like blinking at you
foreign
Australian version that's [__]
amazing yeah yeah but it's like also you
bang out like two episodes a day sure it
just seems like uh I I reckon it's the
wave of the future game shows
it reinvented Howie Mandel's career
reinvented didn't it invent no no
I like how he's I like how we like how I
went though I did Howie's podcast yeah
and he said do you think you could call
anyone and I said ah yeah pretty much
it's me thing yeah and he's like can you
ring up my wife and call her and then
like when someone puts it in front of
you like that yeah oh God can I yeah and
so I rang up and he goes uh he Rings his
wife up and he goes Jim Jefferies once
uh he goes someone here wants to speak
to you I'll say who I am I said hey how
you doing
and she goes oh I love you
wow and then I was like oh good yeah
what if I I used to say it more than
most British people did on stage but now
it's like in Australia I remember in the
comedy clubs in like the early 2000s no
one really said it we and now it's like
the whole the gates opened in Australia
every comic saying it and yeah and it's
pretty Island they were always saying it
there